[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre institut comme tu
le sais notre mission première est
d'accueillir et d'aider des individus
doués de certaines capacités hors normes
des élèves de notre institut ont
d'énormes responsabilités doivent lutter
contre des mutants animés de mauvaises
intentions désamorcer des conflits
internationaux bref ils doivent sauver
l'humanité de la destruction et du chaos
ce sens tu prêt à relever le défi
c'est mon rêve depuis toujours
d'intégrer l'institut
as-tu un pouvoir spécial
[Musique]
dans ce cas
montre moi ce dont tu es capable
voilà je peux transformer les objets eux
c'est bien par contre c'est que en
aubergines quoi le légume en question et
uniquement le mardi
maintenant lundi matin oui d'accord
quand j'y pense et on va pas par les
vents dominants
alors soit rassuré il ya quand même une
place pour toi dans l'institut super tu
vas aller en 2b à j'en ai encore un pour
l'adouber et il y en a encore beaucoup à
voir aujourd'hui
2 mais je suis capable de reproduire
parfaitement le sens d'une flûte au
nouveau palais vous rencontrez un très
bon vous voyez quand même je vais faire
des trucs a dit
[Musique]
dégage je ferme m bon bah moi je peux
traverser les murs ça marche pas avec
tous les murs parce que moi j'ai essayé
chez moi sur dumbéa 13 ça marche bien
mais sinon attendez j'ai un autre
pouvoir je peux me métamorphoser
allez-y
[Musique]
hello je suis là si si regardez bien
juste là oui voila voila coucou up et
regarde et je peux même descendre
[Musique]
j'aimerais vraiment su comment garder
mes fringues mais eux c'est bien non ce
qu'il restait de la place en 2 b vite
salut à tous ces matches là ici vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner aux différents réseaux de
côté moustaches y en a vraiment beaucoup
et si vous avez un super pouvoir vous
aussi genre avoir de l'argent vous
pouvez vous procurer par exemple tee
shirt que lucien portait au début de la
vidéo et plein d'autres produits sur le
golden score alesi cliquer j'ai
peut-être penser un habillez moi